over this past holiday weekend in the
past week it's been pretty wild in
Europe we've had some pretty serious
stories about children being Gravely
injured or killed by by uh immigrants in
one story it is quoted as the man saying
we are here to stab white people so
there there are now there have been
riots in Dublin over this with Conor
McGregor speaking out saying we are at
War and slamming politicians for forcing
immigrants into these parts of Ireland
you've got a video of shin fine which is
the leftist political party in Ireland
getting heckled and in France in Lion
you've got protests in the street people
saying France wake up you're under
attack and so it's getting particularly
interesting especially when you consider
G Wilders winning in Holland and the
media reporting is the far right winning